pamela starts off this hour in fort
lauderdale hi Pamela how are you hi Dave
I'm so nervous to talk to you I'm so
happy to talk to you oh my goodness I'm
great thank you how are you better than
I deserve
Merry Christmas how can I help I'm going
back and forth between I'm in baby step
number two I'm going back and forth
about if I should keep my car or get rid
of it because if I get rid of it I won't
have a car to drive and I know you say
you shouldn't be saving and baby steps
to so I don't know if I should just keep
the car just keep panning off or Ellis
I'm just anxious to get to Sally mate
that's why okay so how much do you owe
on your car eighteen thousand sixty nine
okay what's it worth if I do private so
I know someone it's fourteen between
14,000 to 15,000 and if I go to the
dealer between twelve to thirteen
thousand okay and what's your household
income
three thousand how much other debt do
you have I have 47 and Sally main and
others are like doctor bills
it's like collection stuff I don't even
look at those yet because the biggest
pet is Sally main the 47,000 yeah and so
rent round numbers you got $70,000 in
debt and you know eighteen of it is your
car yes and you make sixty and it sounds
like you're single are you okay all
right cool all right
what I do if I were in your shoes well
my rule of thumb is if the car is worth
more than cars vehicles anything on the
motor is worth more than half your
annual income you have too much tied up
in things going down in value this one
is not it's less than half your annual
so that's safe the second rule is can we
be debt-free within two years if we keep
the car
or if we sell the car does it make a big
difference in you being debt-free in two
years the answer to that one is yes you
would I said three okay
well - if you sell the car if you can't
be depth you can't be debt-free in two
years if you keep the car it'll be three
get out of here yeah yeah I really
thought if you sell the car you can do
it in two and so how do you do that well
I mean you're gonna move from an $18,000
debt on a car to a three thousand plus
about a three thousand dollar car so in
your six thousand dollar debt seven
$18,000 debt I think that isn't I think
that is worth doing but how do you do
because I have no money save and I know
you suggest like what you think if you
have me facing them baby steps - I don't
have any money I understand understand
we go to your credit union you sit down
with your local bank and you talk to
them about a six thousand dollar loan
three to cover the purchase of a car and
three to cover the hole that you're in
when you can find a buyer you don't take
this loan until you find a buyer but
when you find a buyer for 15 you go get
the loan for six three of that is used
to cover the hole that you're in three
of that is used to buy your next car oh
okay okay
good okay now that was my question the
other question is this what you do for a
living I'm your what a physical
therapist assistant okay can you started
doing ooh BRR last Saturday it was my
first day okay
see if you can pick up a bunch of extra
income and we can get this down close to
two years and you want to keep the car
then you could fight your way on through
it I just don't want you to be in debt
forever because of the car and the car
the sale of the car does move the needle
on the math I mean it does help you get
through the math here and so you know
once you know that then yeah I'm
probably selling it but you know if you
could find something where you're making
like you know if you get if you in your
area if you can make 1,500 on uber a
month and you're willing to do that is
extra work in order to keep this car
1500 a months gonna pay you often or
extra year early then we may talk about
keeping the car
but that's a - that's two years of no
life while you plow through this and
that's in order to keep the car right
yeah I don't care right now I'm so
hungry for it like oh my god
I listen to you everyday like opening up
a Bible yeah you got it
you're on fire you're gonna do it I'm
proud of you well done keep it up now
let me know how I can help is your fight
through I want you to win you're on
you're on the right track to do it hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]